et maintenant comme chaque dimanche à la
même heure laissons-nous entraînée par
françois chalais qui nous emmène au
cinéma ce soir ce n'est pas un spectacle
ou très familial qui nous propose en
tout cas un film qu'il n'a pas du tout
mais pas du tout aimé le dernier film de
pasolini sortie presque clandestinement
pendant le festival de cannes salo ou
les 120 journées de sodome de pasolini
ont été ainsi victime d'une sorte de
conspiration du silence excellente
raison pour en parler
aux yeux de certains pasolini et
l'archange d'une morale nouvelle pour
les autres au contraire pas de doute à
avoir c'est un enfer qu'il est en train
de griller en réalité toute sa vie il a
essayé de se mettre en règle avec ses
propres contradictions se vautrant à la
fois son corps et son coeur dans la boue
de cette boue mais ni lui est arrivé de
faire jaillir des diamants chez lui l'or
et les excréments étaient indissociables
ces 120 journées de sodome suivre à la
trace celle du marquis de sade écrivain
dont la folie notoire au xviiie siècle
passe aujourd'hui pour le signe de la
plus éclatante santé mentale ainsi va le
progrès là aussi on voit un duc un
évêque un financier un magistrat à
l'abri dans une villa coupés du reste du
monde
this livrade a trop exactions sur un
sérail de garçons et de filles maintenus
en esclavage par une voyoucratie
milicienne richement dotée dans les
parties basses de ces individus mais on
a actualisé le sujet on l'a situé au
printemps 2009 144 après de salon une
petite ville du nord de l'italie où
mussolini s'était réfugié avait tenté de
faire surface
après sa libération momentanée par les
ss corzine
disons le tout net rarement un film nous
a donné autant envie de vomir comme
pardonne mais ce ne sont que festin
malodorant ces avis dans des pots de
chambre
orgie de langue coupée dieu crever
flagellation de filles est réduite à
l'état de chienne mendiants à quatre
pattes une insectes bouillie qui se
révélera par la suite truffé de cloud on
imagine ce que cela peut donner
après un certain nombre de mastication
vous vous indignez vous n'êtes
décidément plus dans le vent de tous
côtés en effet à grand renfort de
citations de roland barthes de simone de
beauvoir des esteys à la mode vous
expliqueront qu'il s'agit d'une année
dénonciation du facisme il suffit d'être
prévenu bon je n'ai jamais eu le goût de
piétiner les morts mais je crois que
sans attenter à la mémoire des disparus
on peut estimer qu'il y avait d'autres
moyens plus digne que convaincant de
condamner l'infamie totalitaire que
c'était à l'âge complaisant de torture
et de perversion que cette rafle le
voyeur de la pire espèce qui se délecte
aux exploits de plusieurs dangereux
maniaque pauvre pasolini emporté par les
fantasmes qui creuseront sa tombe
il a voulu se déculpabiliser en tâchant
de culpabiliser les autres il a échoué
et le cadavre de son alibi ne sent pas
bon